wenn ich sage dass dieser impfstoff
massen üblichen regeln entwickelt und
geprüft wurde dann bezieht sich das
darauf dass wir a gesichert haben dass
ein hochqualitativer impfstoff
hergestellt werden kann der auch in
bezug auf die herstellung den üblichen
regeln entspricht so dass wir das safe
sind und die chance prüfung stellt ja
auch noch mal durch unsere unabhängige
prüfung seitens des
paul-ehrlich-instituts sicher dass
dieser hohe qualitätsanspruch auch für
dosen jeder charge und nicht nur bei der
zulassung gewährleistet ist nummer zwei
die entsprechenden pharmakologisch
toxikologischen untersuchungen ob diese
ansprechen
am tier wurden vollständig durchgeführt
wir haben hier eine beschleunigung
dadurch erreicht dass einige dieser
prüfung nicht wie üblich vor der
erstanwendung menschen sondern parallel
zu den ersten klinischen prüfung
durchgeführt wurden das hat einfach eine
große zeitersparnis gegeben nummer zwei
wir haben weiterhin es geschafft
klinische prüfungsphasen miteinander zu
kombinieren und durch einfache verfahren
hindern unter übergehen zu lassen ohne
dass hier dabei allerdings abstriche
erfolgt sind und sie wissen das ja
gerade der bau und werkstoff weltweit an
vielen über 10.000 probanden getestet
wurde und hier die ergebnisse ziemlich
klar sind und ja zu dem zeitpunkt der
zulassung eines impfstoffes sind die
langzeitbeobachtungen nie vollständig da
diese werden jetzt nachempfunden aber
ich kann sagen dass wir daten wir haben
auch schon früh ins rhön klinischen
russen kämpften die keine besonderen
auffälligkeiten gezeigt haben über
monate nach der entsprechenden zusatz
bitte verstehe ich das richtig wenn ich
das jetzt als laie zusammenfassen dass
sie sozusagen die zeit komprimiert haben
dass die neue techniken und methoden
haben mit der sie diese fünf jahren ein
jahr unterbrechen und wenn ich das
richtig verstehe warum konnte man das
bisher noch nicht machen warum geschah
dieser durchbruch ausgerechnet jetzt in
dieser an dem ihn aber ich kann den
berichten von der zeit als wir
die ebola epidemie in westafrika hatten
hier wurde ebenfalls sehr schnell ein
impfstoff entwickelt und die
entsprechende komponente von unserer
seite habe ich genannt dann kommt
natürlich die entsprechende finanzielle
unterstützung dazu die fokussierung
nicht nur der regulatorischen behörden
sondern auch der entwickler auf diese
entsprechende entwicklung so dass wir
auch hier relativ schnell zu guten
sicherheits und wirksamkeitsdaten kamen
zu dem damaligen zeitpunkt haben wir uns
allerdings dann mit der zulassung einige
zeit lassen müssen
das heißt also wir haben gelernt wir
verbessern uns immer weiter und ich
denke wir müssen schließen dass wir auch
aus dieser epidemie wieder mitnehmen
müssen dass wir gewappnet sein müssen
für die nächste für die miete wer kommt
und hier das gelernte weiterentwickeln
und ich denke wir dann auch oder werden
das in den nächsten monaten und im
nächsten jahr erleben das glaube ich ein
impfstoff der game changer bei der
bekämpfung von paris st mehr nachrichten
und breaking news nur bei bate schau
dich hier das nächste video an und
vergiss nicht zu abonnieren